you
hi everyone is cheering let's have a
look at a game from 2015 between Czech
Grandmaster David Navarro playing on the
white end in Polish Grandmaster rata
slaw boy taschek this is quite the King
walk we have here I've seen many King
walks and this one might just be the
king of them all let's see what you
think
Navarro opens with e4 boy taschek
replying with the Sicilian defense we
have an open Sicilian what variation
Knight Orff and with Bishop III this is
noted as the English attack looking for
some race type position opposite sides
castling throw pawns at the enemy King
each side looking for checkmate we don't
quite enter that type of play in this
one but this is the general idea behind
this line ePHI follows night b3 Bishop
e6 and white now preps this King side
expansion with h3 looking for next for
g4 I'm more used to seeing f3 instead of
h3 both have the primary function of
supporting g4
if you're looking for a difference
between these two moves here's one to
know with the pawn on h3 instead of f3
the Queen's eyes stay open to h5 how
might this factor in well one day when
the pawn races up to g5 the knight will
no longer have the option to go to h5
sometimes the knight would like to do
this kind of put a halt to the White
King side pawns and especially the H
pawns saying you're not going to go any
further you have to work around my
knight well now if g5 is in the knight
will certainly have to drift towards the
Queen side continuing Bishop e7
sure enough g4 and not black sneaks in
this almost always desirable break in
the Sicilian d5 he takes d5 Knight takes
d5 and more development wifey and kiddos
Knight takes Bishop whiten exchanges
Queens first demoting one of the black
pieces now have to recapture and go
backwards only now do we have the
capture on e3 so let's just pause for a
moment 13 moves in what's changed with
these last handful of moves structure
for one isolated pawn on e3 and black is
working with two bishops in particular
the dark square Bishop it's the one you
should keep a close eye on that's the
one that can give white a problem fast
and does Bishop h4 immediately that's a
check the White King is now and castled
the same time b7 is under fire so how to
cope with this black develops Knights e5
two things I hit the bishop in the fun
first things first
Bishop gets out of harm's way and throws
a punch
kingi one in black simply queenside
castles defending b7 connected rooks
white is uncle but now we have b3
well we're noticing here the bishop on
baton c4 is very short on squares where
is there a safe square for the bishop to
go to not many options just to highlight
if black reacts to this threat with
let's say Bishop e6 this would be a
wonderful way for black to enter a
strategically busted position
this Knight would no longer be worth
three more like seven he cannot be
chased away by a black pawn and he is
not accessible to either black rook
of course this guy isn't gonna harm him
and he also controls entry squares from
the black rooks cannot put a value of
three and that guy so this is the issue
that black is confronted with you can't
react to this threat you have to go on
the offensive you have to look for some
counter attack and black does Bishop g5
we're going to notice over these next
handful of moves is that the dark square
Bishop is super excited about the
squares g5 and h4 constantly bouncing
back and forth on these two and there's
a serious threat connected with this
last one
Bishop g5 says you take my bishop I take
your pawn and then your knight Bishop
III would hit with check so III is
defended
but the bishop returns to h4 now
throwing a punch at the rook rook - well
where should the RIP go this is one of
the interesting things to note about
this game the rook could very well have
gone to a-1
at this stage here the bishop going back
to g5 the rook would come to e 1 and we
would have one of those where they call
Grand Master draws kind of you know some
quick draw under 20 moves players shake
hands called a day and nobody ever gets
to see the game nothing exciting happens
well something certainly exciting
happens in this one because we don't
have rook be rook a one we have rook b1
now on the surface it appears b1 a1
they're both closed files what's the
difference well there's a key difference
okay it's that in some lines when the
bishop is captured the rook is brought
to life he's controlling b4 b5 b6 these
are the two key squares B 4 and B 7
there's some lines that are that I will
be highlighting where yeah this factors
in having the rook brought to life along
the B file
okay following up Bishop g5 we don't
have the rook returning how to defend
III King F to this is quite the fearless
King I must say Bishop h4 King f3
forward
efore check King f4 the king will be
stepping foot on every single one of
these F file squares now in this
position if the rook was on a 1 instead
of b1 black is winning I'd like to
highlight one line that would lead
straight to check me this is what it is
g5 King f5 or a d2 chop again
envisioning this position as if the rook
is on a1 this is how white could end up
losing check King takes pawn check King
d3 and the knight would be able to now
pivot on b4 and this is a key key move
that would result in checkmate again
assuming the rook is on a1 this move is
not possible in this in this case check
this move would lead to mate right away
check check check
check-check me why am i showing this
line
it's because you need to as white before
you even go on this crazy King walk you
have to know that it's gonna be okay
this isn't one of those well let's just
flip a coin maybe I get mated no it's
not one of those okay this is worked out
this is just one of the many lines that
are worked out white knows he's not
going to get made
okay so king f2 it is f3 f4 he's not
done f5 is now on board rook to e8 this
is serious there's still and I know the
Queen's aren't on the board but there's
still a lot of traffic around white is
just a moment away from getting mated
how close there's a mate and to threat
what is it well let's just make a dummy
move to highlight a3 we have rook d6 in
rook to e5 how you stopping that you
only have to you could only do silly
stuff like Knight to g3 I take your
knight and then mate next that's how
nearby checkmate is
how's this parried rook to d1 there will
be no route to d6
rookie 5 King f6
Rick to GA pawn takes Bishop aha
the B rook is brought to life and in a
future line there will be some rook
takes b7 depending on what black does
that might be a way to be defending the
seventh rank let's see how play follows
rook g6 King takes f7 rookie 7 King take
King to f8 rook f6 King g8 rook g6 King
h8 this is beautiful starting on e1 f1
g1 f2 all the way up the F file hangs a
right and goes to the corner and he's
okay this isn't a winning position for
white this isn't a winning position for
black but he's okay
King @rx move rook f6 so many King was
there I just felt like I needed to say
King apparently again rook to f1 this is
pairing the main thread on f8
f2 once more maintenance threat how's
this defended gives but gives back some
material rook takes f2 rook takes rook
the other rook comes over defending
against this mate and one threat rook
takes Bishop now you're not getting at
the White King and he's a very active
King as well and so too are these
Knights
rook f8 King c7 and now the knight drops
in the center getting this material back
hitting with a fork and the computers
eyes this is a the best move picking up
a pawn and then there's some fancy
Knight moves and only later do you pick
up the rook but okay immediately going
in for the material grab getting the
exchange back there's certainly not
going to be any mate threats against the
white king in this position in fact he's
a very active King now in this much more
simplified endgame
King takes the knight on c5 and let's
see how this one finishes up we have hey
rook ending all the sudden on board
gee pawn is picked up and eventually
we're gonna have two connected passers
in this one the King mopping up the H
pawn and these guys are just too good at
this stage King g5 King d5 and King F
for the pawns continue to march and well
what to do here actually in this
position if black tries to run with E -
instead of c5 this one quick line if e -
in this position would have a check and
then the rook gets here just in time to
stop that promotion and there wouldn't
be any fancy check and then you know
something like this because this is
still winning 14 wide sometimes that
would be a nice little deflection but
it's not working here so after h5 we
have c5
rook g5 king d4 and after rook to e5
black simply throws in the towel the
idea here is to give a check and then
pick up the pawn next in these two pawns
well sure enough push through but yeah
not this ending this ending isn't the
excitement it's that middle game
position this wonderful King Locke
Queens aren't on the board but two rooks
a knight two bishops
and black with those Queen side pawns as
well plenty of calculation plenty of
calculation needed in that one and that
was just really me just scratching the
surface with the rook to be one move
there's plenty more
I'm sure navara had to calculate with
this
I think king of all King walks anyhow
feel free to share what you think of
this one in the comment section below
and I'll catch in the next video
that's all for now take care bye
you